la tête dans les nuages la famille
farman a marqué l'histoire de l'aviation
elle fait partie des pionniers lancer à
l'assaut du ciel au début du 20e siècle
aujourd'hui le petit fils revendique son
héritage dans une exposition à magny les
hameaux
nous étions fabricants d'avions par moi
naturellement mon grand-père et devant
donc fait des débuts de l'aviation
premiers km en circuit fermé premier
plein de choses pour lui à partager au
monde également une compagnie a pas
d'air france qui est la fusion entre nos
lignes aériennes et trois autres de 1908
à 1941 les frères forman ont conçu plus
de 200 types d'avions magny les hameaux
est l'une des villes où était fabriqué
des moteurs et des pièces à la maison
des bonheurs une centaine d'objets est
exposée il ya une des lignes de nos
avions et le goliath était le premier
avion de ligne au monde et vous avez les
pièces dehors cuisson plus récente qui
viennent de chez dassault aviation ou du
boeing 707 ou du falcon
à 25 ans c'est une idée de transmettre
aux jeunes l'envi de travailler et leur
envie réelle pierre farman ouvrira
prochainement un musée de l'aviation à
saint-cyr-l'ecole décollage prévu dans
quelques mois